the first one I say from my
understanding the essential problems
with epistemology derive from the nature
of language and axioms upon which
various underlying linguistic structures
are based and then afterwards
interpreted as you have seven year
videos the probability that you construe
some of the same definitions of insert
random word person says and in the same
way are virtually zero one of the best
examples I can give for this is the
language that is used in physics it is
widely misconstrued as the pragmatic
meanings behind words in their context
or groves - based from the vague
linguistic constructed views of the
actual linguistic definitions that
people construe so such as the problem
with the word dimension dimension in
which it is understood in a more
semantic sense but not in the abstract
sense in which the word is in flight the
first chapter of Einstein's theory of
special and general relativity I'm
saying stresses that geometry is an
abstract model time per se is not a
dimension the theory of special
relativity merely treats any one clock
time as dimension of an abstract
constant so for the next three questions
I have I want this to be considered as a
means of okay so when I answer that
fundamentally I think the best answer to
that was provided by the American
pragmatist so that would be Willie James
and his crew that would include guy
named Kirk Pierce P ie RC e who has
perhaps he you know the best laws for
the America that the U has ever produced
CS Pierce but his somewhat
underappreciated and but certainly so in
his old life part of the way different
people hone in on the same definition is
to define what an acceptable outcome
would be to their joint interactions and
then to hone their language until they
achieve that outcome and then to
consider that good enough and see Pierce
and his crew basically said that you
could never do anything better than that
so let's say that we're trying to let's
say we're trying to communicate about
how we're going to move
a wheelbarrow full of bricks from one
side of the yard to the other well
basically what we've decided is we've
communicated good enough if the bricks
get moved and so so what you have to do
is you have to set up a practical
surround in some sense around your
conversation and that that practical
surround constitutes what you are
willing to consider as proof that
conversation or that communication has
taken place sufficiently and that's
partly it's complicated it's partly why
the robotics engineers types like Rodney
Brooks discovered back in the 1980s that
you really couldn't have intelligent
machines without embodiment because you
need a real-world target against which
to measure the effectiveness of your
communication because as you said I mean
this is where the post modernists have
it right is that there is a lot of
different ways of interpreting
everything so how do you know when your
interpretation is good enough and the
answer to that is you agree a priori
what would constitute good enough and
when you hit that target then you're
done all right thank you and I'll look
into spears okay yep CS pears yeah yeah
look out the American pragmatist they
got it right man
all right and then um so and then the
next one is on transgender ISM and
conservative strongly boast a biological
and scientific claim of two genders or
two sexes based on what language were
going to use they believe and I believe
rightfully so in biological differences
between males and females but I've never
heard a liberal argue and from my
perspective I think I could partially
combat this but it's an argument that
hasn't been raised from the liberal side
which I think should have biological
differences in the brain women can see
more shades of color on average and men
can have better spatial orientation on
average Stevens but there's massive
neurological and biological differences
between men and women they're well
documented but the theme postmodernist
kind
just assume that the scientists who
conducted the investigations are
suffering from the same virus that they
permeates everything else so they just
discounted yes so is it is it really
crazy to believe that someone could be
born with biological similarities from X
Y brain and biological I don't at all
not at all look okay that isn't the
argument that I'm making the argument
I'm making is that a gender identity is
strongly influenced by biological sex
okay and the problem is is that the
legislation especially the legislation
that's being introduced in Canada argues
that it's not yes and that's just not
helpful it's not even helpful for the
transgender types because some of them
for sure there are people live mixed
biological sex although there are women
who have some cells in their body that
have male chromosomes yes and then it's
not a trivial number for example and
there are people who are born with
genitalia that aren't identifiable and
there are more genuine hermaphroditic
types there's no different no doubt that
there are some men that have a more
feminine personality structure and some
women that have a more masculine
personality structure and then that's
biologically influenced so I would
separate I'm not making a biological
case that there are two genders the end
okay thank you for making I'm making a
biological I'm making a case that sexual
identity is unbelievably powerfully
influenced by biology with certain
exceptions and that those exceptions
themselves might be biologically
determined not in all cases but in many
and so part of the reason I was
objecting to legislation like Bill c16
is because it insists the gender
identity is socially constructed well
it's gender identity is socially
constructed then why can't we just take
transgender people and socialize them
back into their into the normative sex
roles exactly right exactly so that's
part of the reason I was objecting to
the legislation one of the more powerful
arguments and I said this I did a
presentation in front of the Canadian
Senate I don't know if you saw that or
not there's no reason for you to have
paid attention to it but if you look up
Jordan Peterson then Senate you'll see
that oh well
with a professor along with a practicing
lawyer I made exactly that case to a
number of Canadian senators telling them
that by supporting this legislation they
were actually doing a disservice to the
people that they purported to be helping
so that's just it isn't that
biologically there are two sexes
although a pronoun is an approximation
that's true now the days of the
approximation is true
it gets slightly messy because we're our
multiplicity of ways that sexuality and
sex differences manifest themselves and
was a fair bit of variability across all
of those different manifestations and so
as I said you can have feminine man in
the masculine male I'm asking a woman
that happens very frequently um it's
just more often you have a feminine
woman and a masculine man yes all right
that perfectly explains my question okay
so next post modernist thought and I
think you kind of already talked about
this when you said the American post
modernist got this right and that I'm
going to summarize very quickly because
you have already answered but like um
you say that you see scientific realism
is nested in Darwinian competition and
so it's reasonably objective that the
little no that's not quite right okay no
I I would say that it hasn't obvious to
me that there is any truth that that is
superordinate to to the terms it's
established in a Darwinian fashion and
that includes our notion of objective
reality now that's where sam harris and
i had a major disagreement but again it
has it's a consequence of my pragmatic
thinking you see the Darwinian claim
fundamentally is that the only way that
you can come up with a definition of
truth is through an evolutionary model
that uses death as the punishment hmm
being wrong and so one of the things I
was arguing with with Sam Harris about
is whether or our current
conceptualizations of objective truth
are necessarily true in a Darwinian
sense
and if they're not which form of truth
should take priority and I was arguing
the Darwinian truth should always take
priority and Sam was arguing it wrong
well it is particularly light that
stance although one of the well and
that's basically how our argument
what argument circulated around all
right so so problem to see the problem
is is that we never know let's see
what's the problem exactly even our
objective truth is seriously bounded in
ways that we don't understand yes claim
claim it any given moment of having some
sort of fundamental ontological status
outside of it's Darwinian utility
strikes being dangerous especially given
how trans mutable scientific theories
came to be so let's if I'm going to
oversimplify things I'm going to say
that liberals tend to think with the
anterior cingulate cortex of the brain
with future application possibilities
like leanest consequences and concerns
also the part of the brain that's
involved in social conditioning yes yeah
conservative commentator 50 a year ago
yes so um yeah I'm going to read what I
wrote here and for example low
populations in rural areas would
potentially possess more views of self
autonomy working hard family values
increasing population protecting oneself
and one's kind due to the types of
motivations and the hypothalamus being
more applicable to survival while highly
populated areas would focus potentially
more on thinking tolerance community
values stabilizing population
additionally might not focus so much on
protecting life or raising children
these differences could explain vastly
the moral behaviors being ideally or
objectively true based on incalculable
variables so you better family better
run run that one through me again fire
me again it's quite complicated yes it
is so I am suggesting that if we are to
look at a a reason why how people think
and we can look at how people think is
being nested in Darwinian competition
yeah right so if if
there's a low populated area are you
would think okay what traits
incalculable but some somewhat
calculable trips would be a necessary
for them to be raised and what traits
mostly in the hypothalamus I'm assuming
and what traits would be more applicable
for large cities so it's almost
completely possible that the politics of
liberals is perfect for their situation
in the big city in the politics of
conservatives is that's a good ideas
it's one that you should think about
like it is it isn't if it's a reasonable
hypothesis I'd have to think it through
a long time before I before I because
you're suggesting that a conservative
philosophy is more useful you know in a
low populated area yes and I live yeah
it's possible
I don't know it's worth thinking through
all right that's because I've been
thinking about that a lot that's my main
the main thing I think about um and I'm
not saying necessarily directly that but
at least the possibility of that's why
yeah one thing you can do just to some
degree to begin with is just run a
correlation between sizes community and
and and political proclivity you should
go get that down on the line online yep
wouldn't be proof because it might be
that the more liberal types are also
more likely to move to the cities right
in this case you'll be leaving
conservatives behind and it's not
because they're more well adapted by
even it it might be because they're more
well adapt into smaller communities it's
a good idea we I don't know what think
of it but it is worth thinking about
um and we actually we have that data
just through political polls and you'll
see whenever I look at a map it's all
red because the red is in the smaller
areas and the blue looks small it cancer
more people there so it does tend our
it's just long as it's a plausible
hypothesis it might be interesting to
look in the red states only and see if
it's still true there yes all right
so thank you for that and you let that
you think of that as a possibility and
then one last question on religion and
I've been watching your
your psychological interpretations of
the Bible as well as I read maps of
meaning mmm
so I may have missed something there but
this question so neuro physiologically
to my understanding the way the human
brain is constructed is such that
happiness is achieved in the pursuit of
a noble aim rather than the taming of
the goal itself you've talked about this
multiple times yeah yeah yeah that's
that you I would it's not even it's not
happiness precisely but that will do
it's more like a sense of meaningful
engagement which I think is better than
happiness but that's okay we can go with
happiness for now all right so if
there's no noble aim we are limited to
simple pleasures which do not sustain a
popular that's exactly right you're
limited to impulsive pleasures yes and
those are ones that don't necessarily
have a good medium to long-term outcome
so if I am to take a psychological or
more view or moral view of biblical
teaching all right the scientific view
is am i right in construing that the
idea of external happiness without
suffering it exists as a brilliantly
thought-out construct which invokes a
sense of purpose and happiness and if I
am to make that conclusion can I see
those concepts in the moral psychology
of the Bible as manipulative or does the
defiance of natural law rule out a
literal interpretation okay go back read
that again so if I if I'm to assume all
of this with Heaven and Hell and is it
eternal happiness yes that can you see
that as manipulative as like it does can
you can I mean certainly marks in I
would say for I did as well one of the
problem because Freud thought of you
know religion as let's call it both
manipulative m and immature because it
guaranteed people the certainty of life
after death and it allows them the
comfort of knowing that an all-seeing
father was watching over them okay and
Freud regarded out let's say is immature
and manipulative but he didn't have a
good
nation for why people came up with the
idea of hell because if you are just
going to go for immature and
manipulative it might as well be all
positive right while you put the
negative in there
and you can say skeptically well hell is
where you put your enemies but that's a
really cynical interpretation because
many religious people and now certainly
even but certainly throughout the Middle
Ages were terrified that hell was
something that they were headed to not
that their enemies were going to so I
don't think that that's a reasonable
interpretation historically I know Marx
would say that the religion was when do
whatever could to manipulate people so
that the power structures the economic
power structures can stay in place but
given that religion religious structures
and this is I would say particularly but
not only true Christianity have played a
tremendous role in giving additional
voice to the people who are downtrodden
and enslaved that God also historically
that's that's not a historically
credible argument and sometimes that
religious teachings are used to buttress
the people who are in control and
sometimes they're used to oppose them so
I don't find out for a second and then
so no I don't think the manipulation
argument is it I don't think it's a
credible one I mean I understand it and
I'm an admirer Freud you know but I
think guard role I think you got got
wrong and that was certainly one of the
places that he disagreed was profoundly
with Carl Jung and I think he um came
out of it right and Freud came out of it
wrong um and then I think the Marxist
critique of religion it's just like
every other Marxist critique it's like
yeah yeah you can't read religious
religion religious structures as if
they're oppressive power structures only
but you know it's just a reduction of a
multi-dimensional complexity to a to a
relatively predictable human dimensional
interdimensional phenomena so helpful
it's not a helpful intellectual exercise
past its immediate self evidence now
because the self evidence is some
religious people are corrupt like yeah
right obviously that that's fair and
given the I'm taking I'm taking one
have been way out of contact sample of a
huge bundle of things so that's a you
know there's a writer named um I should
tell you about this guy um Jeffrey
Burton Russell Jeffrey Burton Russell
you'd like him okay
yeah he's written a couple of books on
heaven and and a very good series on the
devil as a historian so he's a historian
of the idea of heaven and the idea of
the devil so it's evolving series on the
devil one is Memphis dollies which I
think is the best one but if you're
interested in in in that kind of idea
Jeffrey Burton wrestles a good person to
to take a look at he's credible
um incredible historian and and I think
his books are extremely interesting so
kind he delves into the idea of heaven
in a much more fundamental way than than
the typical especially the typical sort
of casually religious critical post
modernist who always assumes that
there's nothing to it except our
dynamics it's foolish can have enough
minimum is a vision of a better future
hmm even even as even as only that it's
by no means trivial I mean human beings
are about the only creatures that can
imagine a better future and so heaven is
like the archetypal better future yes
and so you don't want to just come all
this that idea to casually because we're
always working unless we're pathological
we're always working for a better future
so and to think of heaven as the idea
that's sort of shining behind that you
know the the complete on ik ideal of the
idea of a better future
that's a perfectly reasonable thing to
think and you don't want to just throw
it away that not be throwing away one of
the greatest ideas of mankind and that
doesn't mean I think the people should
be politically you coke it's not the
same thing yes it's the it's the concept
that that has the psychological effects
on the way people behave um yeah with
that woman yeah that's right and it's
the concept of some value like I think
the difference between the Christian
idea of heaven and political utopian
idea of heaven is that some Christians
heaven is what would be achieved through
the use of truth individual truth and
for the
vertical utopian it would be as a
consequence of the instantiation of some
particular political system those are
not the same thing at all all right and
then we I have about 10 more minutes by
my time so uh yes it is a really good
question thank you um I spent a long
time thinking which to ask because
obviously there's a million questions
you're one of the only people I've had
season that could answer some of the
questions I've had so what do you do um
I I like to think of myself as a
philosopher like Socrates soon I am a
student I go in and out of school I tend
to make money when I need to doing odd
jobs in reality like I don't have a lot
of value on society Society is very
really why your future plans I want to
go into academia I want to do research
oh yeah well you're pretty smart you
know that's this plan those are good
questions um I it's school is expensive
in the types of schools that I I go to
are kind of boring I like if I could go
to your class every day I would be the
happiest person ever but the the type of
teacher is not that they're not
intelligent they just not a Sam Harris
or Neil deGrasse Tyson or drink a person
I spend a lot of time reading reading
through Einstein over and over again
reading through are listening to Neil
deGrasse Tyson I like learning I just
the university doesn't give me
substantial means of learning I don't
feel like I learn much I know I get the
picture I get the picture yeah um the
problem that you've got is that there's
some utility in credentials so you know
there's always the possibility of going
to university for the credentials and
educating yourself at the same time yeah
so just what you really have to do if
you go to university anyway I know it's
a but you know it's always an
uncomfortable meld between what you want
and what should be and what you can get
yes Mark Twain says I never let my
schooling interfere with my education
right yes exactly that does kirkuk yes
so that's what I had
couple semesters left the problem is I
don't know I I have a couple semesters
left I go to University of Michigan the
problem is my motivation which I've
watched a lot of videos on your
motivation and there I can't find the
motivation to do the work if I was at
Harvard or Princeton or Yale where
somewhere I was like challenged where I
would be like I was a huge opportunity
for me here I mean no exam count again
so to build the challenge in for
yourself somehow have you done the
future authoring program the what
programs future authoring program um I I
have done that yes better job I think I
was too focused subconsciously with the
reasons why it would help
um determining why why this would help
me it's helping me because of this is
helping me because of that and kind of
like playing mind games with myself
making it so it didn't really help me as
much yeah yeah yeah well because you
know the fact is given given your level
of let's say intellect you would have to
have a pretty good goal to to you know
it's not a typical for someone to be
very smart and very open but not very
conscientious and I don't know if you're
not very conscientious maybe you are but
what you've said so far suggests that
you're higher and openness and lower in
conscientiousness but what you need to
rectify that if you're if you can
rectify it is this suitably lofty goal
and so in and but but if you didn't do
the future answering program in a manner
that helped you establish that goal it's
probably is going to help you like you
obviously need to reason and fair enough
you know so I guess my goal would to be
going to grad school at an Ivy League
college I would air welcome okay um and
I'll have to I mean at one point hi I
wrote a letter to like basically
everybody that works at the Harvard
admission was my finding the the the
emails and yeah and like set a letter
explaining my situation my family
situation why I didn't get good grades
and I
school why I've never been a typical
good student but I have a large drive
and motivation to learn and I know how
every single professor at Harvard and
I'm familiar with their work I've read
their abstracts in their in the journals
not every single I'm exaggerating but
I'm very familiar and with Yale too and
wanted to go into linguistics and there
I never got a response back and I kind
of just sunk back into life my read and
ignore the the universe type of thing
but I definitely you were guy and you
did set a goal and not sink back into my
behavior like the central dress but
actually going outward cycle yeah yeah
yeah well you know you have a good goal
to go to grow to incredible graduate
school and to pursue an academic career
is a good goal but you also might want
to really think hard about what the hell
you're going to do is that doesn't
happen mmm because you know you're kind
of built for it so it being good pursuit
and you know you sound like the kind of
guy who could use a PhD thank you so
well your questions were smart you know
I had to listen to them hard and you
thought about them a lot and they were
sophisticated so um you know you know
and and that puts you in the talk but I
know one percent of students probably
something like that me it's something
like that felt 1 to 5 percent and so
you've got the right kind of mind for it
and with a mind like that you really you
also really want to get yourself
disciplined because um it's also safer
if you have a mind like yours to get
disciplined because the problem with the
mind like yours is it'll it'll it'll I
you'll be chasing it everywhere like
someone with an ill a badly trained
bloodhound yeah yeah enough stuff that
can be really hard on a person over time
you know because it's easy to be one of
those people that has a tremendous
amount of potential but doesn't have it
realized and why that's a rough life by
the time you're about 40 yes I'm also
what is uh linguistically defined as a
polymath where academia is one interest
that I'm showing you right now because
you're an academic
but I have a wide variety of interests
like music arts yeah well that's your
very high to one to say that's got all
the trait that under than others and
that's where my happiness is high so I
do an other opportunity you know
childish gambino die don't Glover no he
is a he's a rapper
and um stand-up comedian and he's
writing Deadpool he's done yes he's very
very identify a lot with him looking at
him as a role model he does a lot of
different things and he were I don't
know his the profanity in his work makes
it discredits his talent by a lot of
people but like so did Shakespeare
I mean basically what the things he says
is witty and funny and profane of course
but so with Shakespeare you know for the
time but I identify a lot with him well
I'm afraid I have to bring our dork to a
halt on because I am someone else's
right up here but